foreign
this is talk TV
tonight up here's Morgan uncensored from
New York and jaw-dropping World
exclusive on the days Sue by the family
of George Floyd I'll talk to yay
formerly Kanye West
okay awesome confusion it's under crisis
for his trust again now A Home Secretary
is out who's next and who the hell is
running Britain
plus he's a legendary chess Grandmaster
and a thorn in Vladimir Putin's side
Gary Kasparov joins me on the war in
Ukraine
[Music]
from New York this is Morgan uncensored
well good evening from New York City and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored prime
minister Liz truss faced an historic
questions today in Parliament probably
the first PM queues ever held by prime
minister who's not really in charge of
the country or even her own party sadly
after all the questions there are no
answers only more questions and
Chancellor says that pensions might not
rise with inflation Liz trust says they
will so which is it who should we
actually be asking tonight the Home
Secretary as well Braverman has quit or
been sacked by Liz truss or maybe the
chancellor who the hell knows it's all
complete chaos but the only thing we did
learn for sure today is that for reasons
best known only to her this trust
remains very very pleased with herself
I have been in office for just under two
months and I have delivered the energy
price guarantee making sure that people
aren't paying six thousand pound bills
this winter I've reversed the National
Insurance increase and I've also taken
steps and we will be taking steps to
crack down on the militant unions
as the late Queen Once put it
Recollections may vary what trust could
have said is I've been in office to just
under two months I've crashed a pound
I've worked 300 billion off the markets
I've done a 20 billion black hole in the
budget I've sacked my best mate lost
control of my party just had to fire or
maybe lose my Home Secretary and drag
the Tories to our lowest poll rating in
history I guess there just wasn't time
for everything right trusts also seemed
very you to make sure we know exactly
who's in charge
I I had to take the decision because of
the economic situation to adjust our
policies
but she didn't take the decision did she
it was the chancellor and he didn't
adjust her policies he nuked them with a
ballistic missile reversing every single
thing she wanted to do as labor zakira
starma said it's all gone
they're all gone so why is she still
here
[Applause]
fighter are not a quitter
no the slamming of the folder on the
dispatch box with an audible thud the
Prime Minister equivalent of a spitting
out of a dummy I agree though you are a
fighter mistrust you're fighting your
own back benches you're finding your own
cabinet you're fighting the markets and
you're fighting for what remains in your
political career on behalf of the
country I now say this it's time you
stop fighting and became a quitter
well joining me now is the former
director of White House communications
under Donald Trump Anthony scaramucci
you thought things were bad there
Anthony welcome to British politics
editor at large at the U.S financial
time Jillian Ted the time political
sketch writer Quentin lets and talk TV
the glory to Kate McCann so an awful lot
to go on Kate McCann let me start with
you I've seen some political basket
cases in my time this just about takes
the proverbial biscuit this looks like a
government completely in chaos ministers
resigning left right and Center no one
sure who's in charge a rudderless
country with a lame duck prime minister
am I wrong
well there are certainly lots of
conservative MPS because who would agree
with you tonight and it's probably going
to get worse still because in the next
couple of hours there will be a vote
here in the House of Commons which there
are a number of MPS now publicly saying
they will defy the government on now the
government has made that a confidence
vote in the Prime Minister it sounds
complicated but if any MP defies a vote
that is a confidence vote in the Prime
Minister then they are effectively
sacked the sacking your MPS at a time
when you're already under increasing
pressure is not the place that you want
to be particularly after you have been
forced essentially to sack Your Home
Secretary although the letters between
the pair say that Zoella Brevin has
resigned it's clear from the tone of her
letter at least that that was certainly
not something that she wanted to do or
feels that she ought to have done in
fact she talks about the transgression
essentially sending confidential
information information that was cabinet
level to an MP in Parliament using her
personal email address is something that
while she recognizes is wrong is
something that has happened before
important that that information wasn't
particularly sensitive I mean one of the
most telling lines in that letter from
Zoella Braverman is where she writes
pretending we haven't made mistakes
carrying on as if everyone can't see
that we've made them and hoping that
things will magically come right is not
serious politics I mean I think it's
pretty clear from that how she feels
about what's happened here this
afternoon the big question now is will
it prompt a further Rebellion against
the Prime Minister which could
ultimately be the end of her
I mean Kate I I honestly can't remember
a situation where a a prime minister of
only 40 odd Days is now so weakened uh
so under attack from never mind anybody
else her own party her own cabinet her
own back benches how could she possibly
survive what's the point of Liz truss
anymore
yeah I mean I think that that's the
problem she now has because the person
that she's appointed in replacement for
Sue Ella Braverman is Grant shapes and
MP who everybody here knows has been
openly plotting with back bench
conservatives against Liz truss over the
last couple of weeks he's been
maintaining a spreadsheet running around
Parliament laughing about it to then
appoint him to one of the most senior
positions in your government is an
indication for many that Liz truss is
not the person now in charge and then in
fact Jeremy Hunt the chancellor is and
that this is an appointment that he has
designed in an aim as we've been talking
about over the last couple of days to
show MPS in the conservative party that
it is it is him and the cabinet who are
powerful in this situation and not the
Prime Minister as one would expect I
mean there are increasing tussles now
between all of those ministers at the
top level and it has to be said that
both Zoella brevmond and Liz trust had
had a row over immigration over the last
couple of weeks I mean Braverman has
been very clear the numbers need to come
down she had a very determined message
on immigration whereas Liz truss it's
understood had wanted to in increase the
number of skilled workers coming to the
UK in order to help boost growth we know
one of the biggest problems she now has
to solve so there was tension there
those inside number 10 and around this
decision say that wasn't the reason for
this sacking but that's certainly how
it's seen by some on the right wing of
the party and as I said that's just
going to inflame tensions further in a
situation where she's already under you
know a huge amount of pressure
right Kate McCann thank you very much
Quentin let's I mean a prime minister in
power but not actually with any power it
seems
yes I and in a way this is worse than
Theresa May because with Theresa May you
had a sense uh that at least she herself
was a serious proposition uh and with
Liz Truss I'm afraid today the laughter
in the House of Commons was uh pretty uh
shaming for her sometimes politics peers
is dramatic sometimes it's melodramatic
sometimes it's just plain nuts and we're
in the we're in that last category today
that place that old Victorian building
behind me today is like one of those
Wild West taverns where there's been an
enormous shootout and there's only the
brothel pianist left and uh today's
events suggests that the end is going to
come quicker uh from his truss than uh
maybe I would have said even three hours
ago it's moving that fast
and she would be the what the the
shortest serving prime minister ever
would she
actually would and who knows if the next
one will last any longer uh but I
suspect that there will be a realization
at some point in the Tory party that
there's frenzy this fever the fever is
running very very high at the moment uh
can not continue they don't want a
general election on the conservative
bench it's because they'd be wiped out
so uh I suspect that at some point the
laws of Common Sense must apply
themselves but you keep on saying that
and it keeps on not happening
yeah I mean we aren't completely
unprecedented territory as things stand
with the polls if that was to be with an
election say next week you'd have to
complete Wipeout of the conservatives
yeah we're not going to have an election
next week because elections take a month
to organize uh so there may be a chance
for a little bit of improvement in the
opinion polls but I just don't think I
mean there's a conservative majority at
the moment of 80. uh it may be a bit
lower by the ascent by the end of this
evening but even so uh the Parliamentary
arithmetic is is okay for a bit of uh
stability at the moment so let's see
that in government and the uh the the
the the madness at the moment is to do
with uh partly with the markets but also
to do with bad feeling that stretches
back to most recently to the toppling of
Boris Johnson remember Boris Johnson was
about Five Points behind in the opinion
polls they must be wondering why did we
get rid of them
well there is a question many
conservatives are asking
um Quentin let's thank you very much and
even joining me I appreciate it well let
me turn to my stellar pack here uh
Anthony's garamucci the mooch I mean
famously you were at the White House for
11 days yeah don't say ten right I mean
by British Feelings by British political
standards this is quite a long-running
quite a long running position yeah well
I got her at under three scaramucci's
now I sort of think that she'll be out
of there by the end of the month what do
you make of it well it's a death by a
Thousand Cuts now and so it's
unsustainable to stay in their position
and so if she is a fighter and I'll take
her at her work she's a fighter then she
should fight for the cause of the
conservatives and she should step down
to help them coalesce and rebuild their
support if she stays in the position
that she's in she's too mortally wounded
and sometimes you go into denial as a
politician and I hope she's not going to
do that in this case I mean Julian the
problem is what does she fight for
because her entire leadership campaign
built up to this mini budget where she
was going to do all the things she
promised to do she then did them despite
warning some Richie sunak who opposed
during that leadership race that it
would all be a disaster it was an
instant disaster so everything she
stands for actually has gone up in smoke
how can she fight for smoke at this
point what she's standing for is showing
that she can tough it out maybe we
should call it trough it out no I think
that's gonna be the new meme
um and I think she's literally trying to
show that she can survive and she's a
proper leader and that she has the
ability to withstand all of these
attacks and come through
um and this trusting it out has become
an end in itself not a means to an end
unfortunately it really is about her
personal practice Jeremy Hunt the new
Chancellor basically disagrees with her
about everything to do with economics
you now have a new Home Secretary Grant
chaps who was Kate McCann was saying has
been one of the plotters trying to get
rid of it for the last week he's now got
one of the great offices of State this
to me you know I've been around the
political game in England for a long
time this is looks to me completely out
of control well I think what the mooch
can certainly say is that when you're in
that situation that febrile environment
where everything is spinning hour to
hour you know moment to moment you don't
know who your friends are your enemies
are it's very hard to actually stop and
make a rational calm decision you need a
serious Mentor you need a serious friend
friends to basically put their arms
around your shoulder and say hey stop
trying to tough it out Truss It Out try
and actually get a real sense of what
you're fighting for as much says and the
merch actually had the um you know
courage to actually quit and say I made
it I agree I mean two things one you did
and I thought that was very principled
at the time that you did that but you
also work for somebody who in a way
there's no greater fighter or Scrapper
probably in world political history than
Donald Trump he might be able to get
through this kind of thing because he
had the strength of character to but
yeah totally different government but
I'm talking about strength and character
to Barrel your way through chaos and
disaster I just don't think Liz truss
has it in her well I love both of you
but I actually got fired okay just so
everybody knows okay John Kelly fired
that's true I didn't quit okay and so by
the way I probably should have quit at
that moment uh but I got fired
but this case is a little different in
my mind and I'm not a obviously a UK
citizen but I'm looking at this she's in
trouble she should quit but there's
something else going on in the body
politic that you have to pay close
attention to the British are unhappy and
they're unhappy with all of these
politicians they want to throw everybody
out and so who's ever going to take
charge better figure out a way to calm
down the British public and come up with
some sensible policies so that people
are not sitting in those pubs saying
let's throw all these bums
don't want to be told what I want to
hear right you know when I go back to
the UK in a week or so I want to be
given some proper home truths this is
the state of the country and its
finances this is what is likely to
happen in the next six to nine months
based on all our predictions this is
what we need to do to get through this I
would rather that a bit of tough love
than the current load of nonsense we've
been spewed yeah absolutely and it's not
just about the British public I mean
it's primarily about the British public
but the reality is the financial markets
want some of that tough love too and
Clarity we need to get real here and
recognize that we're not for the fact
that bank of England has actually
handled the last few days pretty
cleverly the run-up to this wasn't so
great the last few days of Bank of
England has done a good job in calming
things down for the moment but by the
skin of its teeth and we could be
looking at real chaos right now in the
markets and you know the reality is it's
never good to lose a prime minister in a
hurry and a whole series of ministers
right now is really really bad because
the markets are on edge it reminds me of
a sports team right yeah is that you can
get really invested in we can't possibly
make another change because all hell
will break loose and it's like actually
hell is breaking loose and sometimes you
just change the leader in a sports team
and it transforms the atmosphere to
really help now as an investor I thought
my Bitcoin position was bad and so I
looked at the British guilds right I
mean they're moving like Bitcoin they
have the volatility of Bitcoin that is
enough for a responsible public servant
to say this is not the right time for me
this is not my moment in history it's a
tough thing to do because I worked their
whole life to get into that position but
if she steps down I think she'll serve
her party well and her country well what
does it say though about the state of
our country we're now up to is it four
or five chancellors in a few months you
know another prime minister we've had
five I think in the last six years I
mean this is really embarrassing though
well two things to say firstly I keep
making this joke about you know the UK
looking like Italy but without the good
food and the
[Laughter]
exactly yeah but I guess the key the key
point to think about is this what the
last contest was between Sunnah contrast
was between a technocrat and a populist
the last few years of politics in the UK
have been increasingly driven by
populist pregnancies as an America what
I think we're seeing now is that the
populist leader doesn't always work I
suspect we're heading now for a period
of Technology potentially hypothetically
be heading for another referendum about
Europe I mean if security was to win an
election most polls now suggest that
British people would vote the other way
there's been no tangible benefits of
brexit to shut about at all in fact the
opposite I mean could we have another
referendum I think nothing can be ruled
out in the future and let's not miss
either fact the Jeremy Hunt is somebody
who has hardly been antagonistic towards
Europe in the past right
um so I wouldn't be at all surprised if
one consequence of this is technocrats
come back Hunter the technocrat you
start to see all kinds of things begin
to be reconsidered and I think most
people would just like to wipe away the
last few years or some kind of bad dream
you can't do that but with lift trust
stepping down that would be one way to
start just quickly the British economy
was nine tenths of the German economy
before the brexit it's now seven tenths
yeah that's all I would say listen I
voted to remain but I've always said to
my brexit friends I hope it works now
we've done this I respect those who
voted the other way the country was
split in half but in some State at some
stage as the years go by you've got to
start seeing a win for brexit it's going
to be something that shows I mean the
country is improving because of it all
I'm seeing at the moment is the opposite
um great to have you both what a
brilliant team to have on a day like
this it's always breaking chaos and news
Well coming next to a bit of a gear
change I go head to head with yay
formerly Kanye West a remarkable
interview I spent two hours with him
this morning uh with one of the most
controversial minimum planet right now
and he makes money makes pretty
extraordinary admission plus reaction to
that mission with Gene Simmons of Kiss
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
from New York now to my extraordinary
exclusive interview with yay previously
on the course is Kanye West one of the
most famous and influential artists in
the world has been causing Global
outrage over the past two weeks with
anti-semitic tirades which led to him
being canceled by social media platforms
I wanted to give them the opportunity to
set the record straight and explain if
he meant what he said well eventually
eventually he apologized for
what he said was hurtful comments about
the Jewish people but it took a while to
get there it was a fiery conversation
passionate it was funny at times it was
explosive it's unmissable television the
full interview will Air later this week
but here's the moment I think we'll get
most people talking
accountability to my pain you're being a
Karen I'm talking about I'm doing it to
the pain I'm not a cow and I'm not going
to cancel you and I'm not going to
uncensor you I'm simply going to
challenge you on what you're saying I
think you don't understand the pain that
you've been causing with some of these
comments and I think that one in
particular I can understand God God
forbid God forbid one comment could
cause people to feel any of the pain
that my people have went through for
years even like the blacks being ushered
to the left during the Civil Rights
Movement no one is cared
okay all right no one is can I I mean
say I agree that the racism against
black people has been utterly deplorable
shameful unacceptable and thank God the
world is beginning to move to a better
place about the way
people like you however however one form
of racism it's in a better place foreign
I was in a position where I've been hurt
and this is the way I had the right to
express myself the point of this
interview is for you to question me and
then for me to answer and say okay even
though the same rules are not applied to
my people if a person with a gun or
drugs is pulled over and has four three
other people in the car they're all
going to jail I'm not going to apply
that to Jewish people for the sake of
this conversation isn't that what you
wanted but you know what you did you
tried the Civil Rights me you tried to
pull me back to a week ago but we're
here today there's been plenty of
Commerce conversations a commentary
since that but you want me to go back to
1960s
let me jump in here's what I want you to
do I want you to repeat have we grown
have we have we have we grown yes how we
grow here's how we grow I want you to
reflect have we grown I'm about to be
growing I'm not in charge of my growth
United charge
okay like this I'm about to suggest to
you how you may grow if you choose to
grow this way and you can you can ignore
me you can ignore me Pierce Pierce how
much money are you worth not as much as
you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer I would love to take your
businesses why would I listen to you
well why do you why do you hate what my
advice is and then work out if I'm wrong
can we do that deal
well the thing is you you haven't given
me any credit or a moment of reflection
for the comparison that I made the
brilliant if I do say so myself
comparison that I made to the cops
pulling over one black person and
locking up to my tweet having issues I
wasted I wasn't done with the sentence
my tweet referring to all Jewish people
I said for the sake of this conversation
I will refer to the business people who
have destroyed me and my people and my
fellow creatives but you didn't even
accept that I gave you that you tried to
push me back into 1960 and tried to push
me back into last week no I didn't okay
I didn't accept that example that I gave
you I understand completely the example
you gave me I think all racism is wrong
I just will that we've grown I would
like you to reflect this because we've
grown if you feel we've grown if you've
now changed what you wanted to say
originally my question for you is do you
now regret saying
on Jewish people are you sorry you said
that
no he matters you should be absolutely
not you know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I
caught I cause hurt and confusion and
I'm sorry for the families of the people
that had nothing to do with the the
trauma that I had been through and that
I use my platform where you say hurt
people hurt people and I I was hurt it's
an uncensored interview you said
something which you've now wished you
hadn't said and you've apologized I
actually think that says a lot about you
right that shows you've got that ability
to be self-aware to understand when you
cross a line I think someone like you
with all your energy and creativity and
your passion you're gonna say stuff the
way that you talk constantly and in such
an extraordinary manner you're gonna
trip up you're gonna say things the
wrong way I don't think there's anything
wrong and when you do that doing what
you just did and saying I'm sorry I
crossed a line I apologize I want to say
that it's wrong to hold an apology
hostage and and I gotta let go of that
and free you know free myself of the
trauma and say look I'm just gonna give
it all up to God right now and say to
those families that I heard you know I
really want to give you guys a big hug
and I want to uh I say I'm sorry for
hurting you with my comments and I want
to word it and not a pres and not like a
political way but in a presidential way
which means what I knew a president to
be when I was growing up
Grandma
so that was uh yay formerly Kanye West
uh it's an extraordinary interview we're
going to actually air almost the entire
thing at the end of the week so we'll
see everything in real context but very
obviously
um throughout the course of the
interview he began I think to understand
the impact of his words which would
cause such offense and finally got to a
place where he apologized to people
who've been offended particularly Jewish
people well joining me now is Fox News
contributor Tyrus along with kiss front
man Gene Simmons let me start with you
Tyrus
we just had to quickly get that that
series of Clips together to try and say
some of the context of what happened
because to start with he was Resolute
I'm not going to apologize and then went
on a sort of long clarification of he
was talking about business people who
had he and his viewer let him down and
so on but there's no doubt the original
comment that he made that he tweeted
which was D platform from social media
it was talking about the Jewish people
in generality and therefore very
offensive well first of all I I would
only know if I would call that an
interview that was a a you sat him down
under the tree of wisdom and that
reminded me so much of of seeing what a
father would talk to an angry son like
you worked through so many emotions with
him to get him to a place to where he
was able to and you really see that over
there that was a tremendous and your
patience because I'm telling you right
now no one else was going to sit there
for two hours right and I think I'll
think long after this interview you're
gonna help him because what I see when I
see ye I see a hurt man his life has
been uh in the in public non-stop
horrible divorce fighting over his
children he's every time he speaks he's
some group will take advantage of him
use him he's a victim of his of his
wealth but he's not a victim and the one
thing he said that I thought just was
poignant and you walked right through it
was I make more money than you how can I
get from you but here's the deal you
can't buy wisdom with money yes and he's
and I look at him as a former bodyguard
if I was his bodyguard I wouldn't have
let him worn the white shirt I wouldn't
have let him do those things even would
have cost me my job because he's helping
other individuals rise they get the
world famous attention but he gets all
the consequences yes and his stuff gets
lost in his anger and his depression
because what he was talking about I get
and a lot of the record companies you
will always see the same day I think
Michael Jackson is probably the biggest
case of that where he had a song with
they talking about me where he wanted to
use the the term
and it came down from you can't use that
word you can't depict this in that way
from the record people but they're just
fine with using the n-word and almost
pushing that so that's where the a lot
of the the anger comes from is be across
the board you don't want your group
disrespected on your record labels but
you're fine with them and it's on the
wrappers as well but that's where the
argument came from but when you're an
angry hurt individual who's basically
working out his emotions in front of a
camera nothing good is going to happen
right and getting him to apologize he
could not have done that without you and
that you should be proud of that it took
nearly two hours for him to I think
reach a place of self-awareness about it
and actually to reach a pace of calmness
enough to say it but Gene Simmons
um you know I think you probably have to
see the whole thing in in real time to
really get to the journey he went on to
get to that place of apology but a I
mean do you accept the apology do you
think the Jewish people should accept
the apology or was what he said such a
line Crosser that he shouldn't be
allowed to even talk about this anymore
Well you certainly put me in an awkward
position I'm not here to speak for Jews
or the Jewish people or anything
although by birth I happen to be one in
fact in Israeli I had no choice in the
matter that's just the uh luck of the
draw let me state in the interest of
full disclosure ye slash Kanye and I
have never met we've never emailed each
other I have no idea what's in his mind
all I know is what the media has shown
me of him and the astute gentleman who
was on before me his comments I think it
sounded true to these years which is
ye Kanye sounds
from everything I've heard it's erratic
behavior from my point of view
respectfully he sounds really wounded he
sounds hurt so he's lashing out I get it
let's let's be clear about this
African-Americans have been tortured
physically mentally culturally for
decades centuries but you're talking to
a people who've been who've heard this
story and have been tortured mentally
physically for thousands of years goes
back to the Bible
which our people wrote and gave to the
rest of you guys so you you have to go
back in history and get a sense of what
all this means you're talking about
African-Americans and Jews Jews have
done well let's let's be clear because
they worked for it but don't kid
yourself racism anti-Semitism exists
right next to each other and we're all
victims in some way or the other by the
ruling establishment whoever and
whatever they are the consensus of the
public but look back at Martin Luther
King do a little research Google and
smogel who's standing right beside
Martin Luther King in a dangerous March
in Birmingham along with Jesse Jackson
and everybody else you got a rabbi
holding a Torah he's right there in the
front knowing full well when he goes
back up north or on East Coast he's
going to get tortured uh you know by
people who have different points of
views so
first of all African-Americans should
understand that Jews understand
the torture and the racism because been
there okay continue to be there Jews are
not the most popular people on the face
of the planet but there are many other
people's races and other peoples who get
racism so the only piece of advice that
I have as somebody in the peanut gallery
I'm not a doctor I'm not a physician I
don't know much about e or Kanye I've
heard I've got friends who are close
enough and so on
if there's medication
I respectfully urge for the gentleman to
take the medication if he's surrounded
by the wrong people get some nicer
people because the most important thing
you have to realize is when you're a
billionaire and God bless them for that
it's the the Majesty the the miracle of
the American capitalist system there we
go in a country full of racism the
capitalist system allowed you to become
a billionaire and as you have to say as
he as he reminded me quite regularly by
the way let's take a short break I want
to continue the discussion off the break
because I think it's a really raise
these other interesting issues too so
stay with me
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to Facebook when I
sent it in New York and with the Fox
News contributor Tara as long as kiss
front man Gene Simmons Tyrus
Cadia walked out halfway through our
interview and it was quite a struggle to
get him to come and sit back uh and I'm
glad I did because then we ended up
getting to where I think he was in his
in his mind he wanted to get to which is
I think he wanted to atone for what he'd
done and the Damage he caused but he was
sort of too fired up and too proud to
actually go there until we got towards
the end there was another thing I had a
I had a sort of confrontation with him
about and that's his very inflammatory
comments about George Floyd which now
led to George Floyd's family suing him
for 250 million dollars over how George
Floyd died
you Cannon has been watching uh yeah to
give him his proper name he's been
watching videos films which has led him
to believe that actually he was on
fentanyl that's what killed him the
coroner says yes it was fentanyl in his
blood but actually it's quite clear the
coroner that actually what killed George
Floyd was the actions of the police
officer suppressing his neck
when you hear that what do you think
well I think it just goes back to uh
he's a tremendous artist he's a he's a
genius in the music studio but outside
uh he falls for things like this listen
this is this was not a debated issue in
this country and it didn't and you know
Mr Simmons made a great point when he
talked about Martin Luther King and it
took a village and it took a Jewish
rabbi and it took Hispanics and it took
different people and we're sitting here
today on a table we have an Englishman a
Jewish rock star and a black Republican
who wears a gold chain talking about a
black billionaire so that pretty much
shows things are going very well I would
just like to point that out for the for
the record but having said that there is
nobody that is questioning the George
Floyd thing except for people who are
trying to exploit it and this is where
Kanye's Fame is his worst enemy because
he says those things and when he says
those things it resonates and he's
therefore his defamation is more is more
dangerous than other peoples and he says
something like that and you always have
to look around by out who he's around at
the time when he makes these comments
and it always seems to fit their
narrative and they benefit from it but
they're not the ones getting sued it's
him and again this everything that came
out his anti-semitic comments the things
that he said about George Floyd were
stupid unexcusable and he should
apologize for them it doesn't it has he
has no base there's no easy reason to
say those things no other than being put
in these boxes and lashing out and again
I cannot applaud you more because you've
done more for him and that interview
that he won't recognize it now but later
on in his life when he looks back he'll
be like because most people would have
got that first hot take of 10 minutes
and him walking out because that's top
Page News everywhere so I applaud you
for staying the course because I can't
think of anyone else that would yeah it
was I Mean Gene Simmons it's an
interesting thing isn't it we live in a
world dominated by social media uh it's
easy to fall down conspiracy theory you
know rabbit Wars isn't it because
there's so much stuff out there a lot of
it is not well sourced it's just people
spewing nonsense but people buy AI into
it and then very quickly they believe it
and that is a problem I think in modern
society
I believe strongly uh look I I read a
lot and so do we all and we're fairly
well educated about the the uh the woke
society and Council culture and you know
all the other stuff that tortures
everybody not just the people uh on this
panel but I just want to go back to the
people that seem to be
away from the mainstream uh culture call
it what you will are hurt
you've got the polarizing political
issue which are people all the way on
the far left or the far right they're
really they don't feel connected to
what's going on in the world so they
resort to all kinds of conspiracies and
hoaxes and whatever just to push their
agenda but let's not forget the pain
okay so it seems to me as somebody in
the peanut gallery
Kanye's is a guy who seems very hurt who
feels uh and perhaps rightfully so being
African-American in America look I I saw
it firsthand I heard horror stories I
lived with a few years with a an iconic
African-American female singer I don't
want to mention your name because I call
her I I I respect her and over too much
I lived with her with her children and I
heard horror stories when she was in the
number one vocal group an all-girl group
in America and went and headlined above
the Dave Clark Five and went down south
to do concerts and on the way out they
found bullet holes in the uh bus this
didn't happen in the 1800s this is in
the 1960s and she and and the girl
groups were not allowed to stay in a
regular Hotel they had to stay in what
was called a colored hotel that was not
too far off in the past
recognize it don't whitewash it as they
say it it's a fact racism exists I get
it
don't throw out the baby with the bath
water ye look you've got lots of Jews
out there and Muslims and Buddhists and
all kinds of well-meaning people who
actually like you and support
African-Americans or or people who are
brown or come from all areas who support
you your throat you're by making these
comments you're alienating people who
are who actually support you Jane I do
think a pain is lying behind a lot of
these outbursts from Kanye I think he's
got a lot of pain there that he needs to
work through and I I was cognizant of
that and that's why I'm glad he having
walked out he then came back and we did
ask we already got to a much better
place actually by the end where he
seemed much calmer and more self-aware
about the impact of his words and that's
the key thing I've got to leave you
there Gene Simmons thank you so much
honestly brilliant perspective Tyrus
thank you thank you really enjoyed that
conversation uh it's a fascinating
interview uh we're going to air it over
two hours on Friday from 8 to 10 p.m
it's me one-on-one with yay formerly
Kanye West and it's an extraordinary
interview
um you can make your own mind up after
you watch it but I do think In fairness
to him you've got to see in context
really what he's really thinking and
where he's coming from and I think
you'll get that by the end of that
interview
well coming next tonight legendary chess
Grandmaster one of the prickliest thorns
in Vladimir Putin's side Gary Kasparov
is here
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
well welcome back to Facebook now
sensors from New York Gary Kasparov was
once a hero in his Russian Homeland in
22 he became the youngest ever
Undisputed Chess World Champion he did
something few in Russia dare to do he
questioned the regime of Vladimir Putin
on stage even trying to run for
president himself in 2013 Cass
Providence family left Russia in fear of
persecution he's since become one of
Putin's most prominent critics and today
Putin imposed martial law in the four
Ukrainian region supposedly annexed by
bogus referenda by the Kremlin tens of
thousands of civilians are being
evacuated from the Kirsten region head
of Ukrainian counter-offensive so I'm
trying to say Gary Kasparov joins me now
thank you very much great to meet you in
person I grew up a big chess fan and was
a huge fan of your of your play and I'm
sorry that I'm only interviewing you
about such a horrendous situation is the
war not about Chess but I want to talk
to you about in a way what is going on
there has become a bit of a chess game
in the sense of Putin thought he'd take
it all very quickly he got repelled by
resilient ukrainians we're now into all
sorts of pieces being moved around
what's your take on it
yeah look I I feel very uncomfortable
comparing this right
Massacre is horrible things to the game
of chess
um or people being killed as we speak
I'm talking more about tactics yes but
even when we look at tactics and
strategy I would still compare it to
more like poker yes it was in
kept bluffing for years and years and he
always knew that you know if he if he
was bold enough to raise the stakes the
opposite side and for him it was always
not Ukraine it was the West Nate and the
United States the opposition would fold
the courts and that was his plan I
attacked Ukraine it's it so they would
they will not be able to resist in three
four days I take Keith and then they
come back to negotiating table now it's
a war and the Putin does what he he knew
best he keeps killing civilians they
already did it in grossnake more than 20
years ago they did in Aleppo it's not
surprised that that the the Russian
general who is in charge of operation in
Ukraine today he's known as a butcher of
Aleppo when you see people like Elon
Musk proposing that there should be some
kind of peace deal what do you think of
that absolute nonsense yeah what kind of
peace deal so it's the Ukraine has to be
liberated it's the anything short of
full liberation of Ukraine it's a
disaster not just for Ukraine it's not
just for Europe for the world because we
are seeing hater that as you know 80
years ago trying to take a foreign lands
by force and he's not going to stop
there Putin made very clear his plans
were not just to take a couple of
regions he wants to stole the Soviet
Union right oh it's probably more I
think it Putin is at war with the
collective West again it's not me saying
that it's he has been saying it over
years and his propaganda machine keeps
repeating it every day now 24 7. it's
the war is about destroying Ukraine it's
about eliminating Ukraine as Nations and
also replaying the the Cold War he
believes that you know with with uh for
um uh a force of will he can compensate
for the deficiency of his troops and to
force the collective West led by the
United States to capitulate Putin was
not that war with Ukraine every day they
keep saying we are at war with NATO with
America we must win can Ukraine win
uh absolutely absolutely that's that's
and that's another Putin's narrative uh
that is being uh trumpeted by some of
his uh uh uh agents of influence uh oh
Ukraine needs our support but they
cannot win why not Ukraine received uh
less that they needed to win the war but
more than Putin expected and they they
doing great they already endured a great
difficulty sacrifices hundreds of
thousands of people have been killed in
in this conflict one third of the
country has been decimated and look they
are pushing back they are the Ukraine is
doing today what NATO was built for in
1949 saving Europe from Russian invasion
yes and look they dismantled the myth
about uh the strengths of Putin's Army
having by the way very little uh from
NATO arsenals that could have helped
them to win the war quicker
I think 93 of Ukrainian people don't
want to give an inch uh seven percent of
ukrainians apparently do have some
sympathy with territory being given back
as they see it to Russia what do you say
to those people well I think is this
seven percent whatever the number is I
think they want to end this this
nightmare right I think it's all the
Death exactly because look if you are
just being harassed day and day and
night as we speak key was being attacked
and uh and you want you want somehow to
get out of that and if you live
somewhere in London in in Western
Ukraine or or you know just in it's even
hierarchy he said maybe we should give
up something but the fact is look at
this 93 even living in this hell they
still don't worry I was in Ukraine in
July interviewing president zielinski
and the first lady and I was really
struck that everybody I met old young
didn't matter uh to a man and woman to a
boy and girl don't give they didn't want
to give an inch to Putin no deals but
that's that's the message we have to
communicate to Americans to bridge to a
German French this is our war Ukraine is
defending our ideals Ukraine today is a
front line of the battle between freedom
and tyranny and the outcome of this war
will Define our future not just you know
Ukrainian territory or you know Eastern
Europe it will affect you know the whole
world from Taiwan to Venezuela God
forbid Ukraine loses Taiwan is in great
danger Ukraine wins look what's
happening in Iran now I think this the
the wind of our freedom was blowing
around around the world and Iranian
mulas even just being uh being in great
danger because of all these
demonstrations they understand it
they're sending everything they have to
Putin because they know Putin's survival
is the only chance to to stay in power
and that's why you know we see dictators
being
gathering together why not we can do the
same why not American Native could be
far more uh um aggressive in in pursuing
uh pursuing this our common goal Ukraine
must win there are Americans a lot of
them Republicans surprisingly it seems
to me who don't want America to commit
any more money to this war they say it's
not America's War what are we doing
there what do you say to them look you
know back in 1939 1940 so there there
was the ironical also Republicans many
of them talked about you know uh making
making deal with Hitler so it's America
first it's it's not original it comes
from 1939 don't send weapons to Britain
it's not our war no it is our it is our
war and I think it's there many of them
are the the short-minded because again
the consequences of Putin winning you
know they're going to be felt everywhere
and the fact is let's say Okay Ukraine
is is is is a War caused caused uh uh
food problems Taiwanese War could cause
a major disruption with semiconductors
and also America's businesses and
Americas
well-being is very much based on of Law
and and the normal international trade
and Communications everything will be in
Jeopardy if you let the uh uh most
dangerous dictator on the planet and war
criminal to have it his way people say
Vladimir Putin is he mad or bad what do
you think or both it's probably both uh
and again I don't want to speculate
because uh or whatever whatever we hear
from Putin's bunker you know should be
treated with great suspicion I don't
know and I don't want to waste our time
in analyzing whether he's mad or bad
whether he'll do this or that we should
look at the facts we should look at at
the battlefield we should do and what we
can uh uh do to help Ukraine and also
stop speculations about him you know
pushing the button because that's that's
that's that's a big argument do you
think he ever would
um I'm not asking you to speculate I'm
aware yo look uh the answer is uh you
might he might but this is not for him
to do to decide alone and the key is you
know that's that's we have to
demonstrate our resolve to his generals
and Admirals that they will pay the
consequences because they will be on the
front line if they know that the cost of
pushing the button is their personal
life they will never do that that's what
I think are you worried for yourself
you're so outspoken about Putin you've
been fearlessly so for many years we
know what happens to people in Russia
who are outspoken about him are you
worried about your own security okay I
don't live in London I live in New York
right so uh but uh the answer is yes but
would it help I mean that's I I can't
stop doing what I've been doing uh so
that's why I grew up you know I learned
from soil dissidents do what you must
also beat
well you're an inspiration to be as a
chess Grandmaster the inspiration for
what you do know thank you very much for
what you do Gary thank you for having me
nice to see you well that's it from me
whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive we'll be back tomorrow night
from New York good night with more from
my my yay interview
and a full interview on Friday good
night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign